PETE WARDEN: Hi.
So I'm Pete Warden, and I'm the
only thing standing between you
and lunch, so I'm going to try
and talk as fast as possible.
So I'm here to talk about
mobile and embedded TensorFlow,
using TensorFlow on mobile
and embedded devices.
And the first question is,
why would you want to do that?
Isn't TensorFlow
and deep learning
something that you do on
massive clusters of GPU machines
in big data centers
in the cloud?
Well, yes it is, but it's
also an incredible way
of offering unique user
experiences that we've never
been able to offer people
before by running interactively
on devices that host to data and
the people that are working on.
Everything from real
time translation,
to predicting next
words on keyboards,
to helping people scan
old photos with photo
scan, to all of
the amazing stuff
that you know Snapchat
is doing in real time,
and as you just saw,
actually trying to help
detect diseases running
real time on device.
So, because it's so important
to us, and because we think
it's such an important
area to be working on.
As you saw in the
keynote we've been
working with people
like Qualcomm
and all sorts of other
hardware manufacturers
to make sure that
TensorFlow runs
as fast and as
smoothly as possible
on a whole bunch of
different hardware.
Once my clicker works.
Yeah, the joke around the
office is we may be on the way
to solving AI, but AV is
still well out of our reach.
So, we are going to talk a lot
more depth about all the sample
code, and documentation,
and build support
we have for Android
iOS and Raspberry Pi,
but if you have something
that's not listed here,
we really care about all
the diversity of platforms
that are actually emerging.
So please do get in touch.
We're really keen to
see TensorFlow running
as many places as possible.
Yeah, still nothing.
OK.
We're going to do this manually.
So, how can you actually
get running on Android?
Well, if you're an
Android developer,
you're probably already
using Android Studio
and TensorFlow can
actually be built
with just a few simple steps
using Android Studio directly.
Oh yeah, so if we
go back one more.
So back.
Yes.
So here we actually show
you how you can actually
alter the build script to let
it know where Bazel, which
is the underlying build system
we use to build for Android,
is located in the
build.gradle file
that we supply as part
of the sample code,
and then you just
add the sample folder
as a new project
in Android Studio
and go ahead and build it.
Now, if you actually want
to get in a bit more depth
and make alterations
to TensorFlow
and do more complex
rebuilding, you
use Bazel, which is Google's
open source built tool.
You grab the latest version.
The URLs listed here, and
you need to grab the SDKs
for Android, both the SDK
and the NDK for the c++ part
of the building, and I like
to use Android Studio's SDK
manager because it makes it
a lot simpler than having
to figure out all the URLs, and
it makes it really easy to have
multiple versions
lying around too.
So make a note of what version
of the SDK you've actually got
and also where it's
located on disk.
And you need to add
to this incantation
to the end of the workspace
file in the source
tree of TensorFlow at the root.
And what this is
saying is basically
which API you've installed
and where about it's actually
living.
And because I actually end
up doing this a lot as part
of my job, I like to keep
this information around
as a little file
snippet, which I can just
do a one line append
to that WORKSPACE file
whenever I set up
a new source tree.
And then to build
the demo apps, all
you have to do is call
this one Bazel build line,
and just as a note, the
build file here is actually
only set up for Android, so
you don't have to specify it.
But for other tools
like the benchmark
and things that can be built
for multiple platforms,
you'll need to specify minus
minus config equals Android
as part of the build process.
So, what you get after that?
The Android examples
are designed
to help you think about
some of the different things
that you can actually do
using TensorFlow on device.
So if you're interested in
ideas on improving your apps,
or new things you can build,
they're a great place to start.
And unfortunately, this
doesn't come with cake.
I could do with some
right now, but this
is the classify example,
and what this is doing
is it taking a live camera
feed, and it's actually
trying to label images using
the Inception v3 network,
the same one that we saw in
the previous presentation,
but for the objects that are
known in the image net class.
And one key thing about
this is you can actually
use the TensorFlow
for Poets tutorial
which is a code lab
which you can Google,
and that lets you train your
own model using Inception
v3 with no coding
required, on images
that you actually
care about, and then
you can take that model and
you can drop it directly
into this sample, and have your
own custom image recognition
app with very, very
little coding involved.
And a couple of
other details, if you
play with the
volume button you'll
get to see statistics about
where the time is going
and other debug
information, and you
might notice with the
default image net model,
if you point it at
people it will come up
with results that are
confusing because there's
no person label in the
image net class set.
So it will show you
things that it often
sees together with people like
oxygen masks and seat belts.
But if you do want
to recognize people,
we have the app for you.
And this is TF Detect, and
what this is actually doing
is drawing bounding
boxes around any people
that it actually detects
in the live camera view.
And here's a
screenshot, but just
to live really
dangerously, I'm actually
going to try and do a live demo
that we haven't even rehearsed.
So I'm going to give some
offerings to the demo gods
and hopefully they
will smile on us.
I am ready to switch over.
So can you-- do we
need more light?
Well, hopefully you can see.
Yeah, that actually helps.
You can see my little nephew
there is being detected
as a person in this
picture, and if you
look at the bounding
box, you'll see
that it sort of
follows him around
as you sort of move the camera.
So before anything
goes wrong with that,
I'm going to skip quickly past.
Since I think I
got away with that.
Yeah.
OK, let's see if this--
no, clicker's still-- oh, OK.
So it uses tracking, which is
really important when you're
doing object detection because
that means you can actually
know which objects are the
same from frame to fame.
So we include a full tracking
solution as part of this demo,
and that makes it really
useful for doing things
like counting
objects because you
know when a new one appears.
There isn't training for
the person detection yet,
but if you look in the read me,
you'll see that the grey open
source project called Yolo,
which actually supports object
recognition, we also support
that as part of the demo.
And finally, you've
probably seen
the Magenta Group talking about
stylisation and style transfer.
You can actually run
this live on the phone
using the stylize example.
And because it's part of
the Magenta model set,
you can just grab the
model directly from there
and train it on any stars
that you actually want to do.
So, if you're
developing for Android,
you're almost certainly
writing your code in Java.
And the bulk of TensorFlow's
core that you're actually going
to be using is written in c++.
So how do you deal with that?
How do you actually call
TensorFlow from your app?
The answer is a thing called
the Android Inference Library,
and if you don't want to
understand what it does,
you don't need to, but basically
it acts as a bridge between
the Android Java
level and the c++.
And you can actually grab
a pre-built binary of this
and an APK of all of
the demos that I've just
shown you at this URL, where
the nightly builds are actually
put.
So if you don't want to
compile the library yourself,
you don't want to compile
the demos yourself,
but you want to give them a try,
this is the URL to check how.
And even better-- go back.
Even better, we actually
have a full Java API
that has just been
created, which
is going to offer a whole range
of access, much beyond just
like loading and
running a model, which
is what the Inference
Library focuses on.
So also check out
the full Java API.
So, if you're
building for mobile,
you almost certainly
care about iOS as well.
So what can you do there?
We have full support
for building for iOS.
We actually use a
makefile to help
us get this running
because we call out
to Xcode's command line tools.
So you need to
make sure that you
have a recent version
of Xcode running,
and also install a
couple of dependencies
you need to help make
files actually run.
And I like to use brew
because it makes life simpler.
But whatever use, just
try to make sure you've
got automate and libtool.
And then all you have to do is
run the build or iOS.sh script
and it usually takes
somewhere around 20 minutes,
and at the end of it you'll
have a universal library
implementing TensorFlow in all
of the architectures plus bit
code, and just in case you
need to dive a bit deeper
and you need to make iterative
changes to the TensorFlow
library, you can run
the individual steps
and they will only rebuild
things that have changed.
And to make sure that things run
as fast as possible, by default
we use the minus
OS flag, optimizing
for size, which we also find
gives a good speed profile.
And we love using Apple's
Accelerate framework
because they offer really fast
linear algebra matrix multiply
operations on iOS devices.
And when you're ready to
use this in your own app,
you need to link against
the TensorFlow library
that you've just created.
You also need to
set up your project
to link against the protobuf
libraries that were created
as part of the previous steps.
You need to add include parts
to the TensorFlow headers
as part of your project so it
can find the dot H's, and you
need to use this
minus force load
flag as part of your
linker ops when you're
building your final executable.
And this is mysterious,
and I'm going
to be explaining why
you need to do this
in more depth in a
little bit later,
but for now, just remember do
this or bad things will happen.
So what can you do on iOS?
Well, you can create some
really, really ugly UI, which
is the demo app that
I first created,
and all this does is has
a single button, which you
tap the button to run a model.
It loads a picture of Admiral
Grace Hopper from the assets
and runs it through an inception
model and prints out the label.
So why does this exist?
It's very simple
and it's very small.
So if you're looking
for something
to start with to look
at how to integrate this
into your own project,
it's a very small amount
of code to look at and
you'll get a good idea
of how to work with it.
But for something more
fun, these are actually
my two cats from home, and
much like the Classify app
that I talked about earlier,
this takes a live camera feed
and runs an inception
network on every frame,
and prints out the
labels on screen
to show what it
thinks it's found.
And just like the
Classify app on Android,
you can take a TensorFlow
for Poets trained model
and drop it into the
example, and have it work
with very, very few changes.
So again, it's really easy to
build your own custom image
recognition app with
almost no coding required.
And I love the Raspberry Pi.
It's a massive amount of fun.
I have so many of them
cluttering up my house,
but it's also a really
powerful platform
for prototyping all
sorts of devices
sort of in the internet
of things world.
So it's a really
important platform for us
to be supporting.
And the good news is
that building for it,
it looks a lot like a
normal Linux machine
that you might have in your
development environment.
The bad news is that it's
an incredibly slow Linux
machine compared to any desktop
or laptop that you're used to.
So the temptation might
be to compile everything
on your fast machine,
cross-compiling for arm
and for the Raspberry Pi,
but I've gone down that route
and I actually found I
hit a whole bunch of very
hard to diagnose problems.
So you might have
better luck, but I
recommend actually
building everything locally
on the Raspberry Pi,
even though it's going
to take a few hours to run.
And to build the c++ core of
TensorFlow on the Raspberry Pi
you need to install a
few dependencies again,
and we're going to be
using the makefile.
So you need a few makefile
dependencies, and also
if you're running on a
recent version of Raspian,
make sure you install GCC
4.8 because TensorFlow
has had some issues with
the arm version of 4.9.
So we found
switching back to 4.8
makes things a bit smoother.
And just as another
note as well,
there's a fantastic
tutorial out there,
if you look for it, for
building the whole of TensorFlow
on your Raspberry Pi,
including the Python parts.
That requires a
swap drive and about
a day of compiling
last time I tried it.
So I like to just start
off with the makefile
so that you can run
models and do inference.
And then to build it you just
run this makefile script.
Again, specifying GCC 4.8
so that you use the version
that you've just installed.
And one fantastic thing
about recent versions
of the Raspberry Pi
is that they actually
have SIM-D acceleration.
They have neon
acceleration instructions,
and so if you want
to take advantage
of that, which you really should
if you can avoid deploying
on Raspberry Pi 1's, you need
to specify these optimization
flags.
And you'll get a
many times speed up
compared to the
normal scalar code.
So what can you do
on the Raspberry Pi?
As is traditional
at this point, we
have a very small kind of boring
example to get you started,
called label_image, and this
is a small amount of code
that loads an image
net inception model,
and it will take an
image file as an input,
and it will run the image
through and print out
what the labels are.
Now, for more fun,
the camera example
actually takes a live feed
from the Raspberry Pi camera
accessory, if you
have one attached,
and it runs through
an inception network,
and it prints out the labels
that finds continuously
to the console.
And again, just
to emphasize this,
you can take a model that
you've trained with TensorFlow
for Poets and drop
it into this example,
and have something
running that's
running your custom image model
for things that you actually
care about.
And just for fun, I've
actually tried to set things up
so you can just
pipe on the command
line, the output of
this tool into flight,
and have your Raspberry
Pi sort of saying
what it's seeing as you
point it around the room.
OK.
Do you remember I
mentioned minus minus force
load with lots of mystery?
Well, you'll need
to know about it
when you run into this error.
You've built your
app successfully.
You've managed to link in,
get all of the header files
and everything else set up.
You've written the code.
Everything's compiling.
You've run your app
trying to use TensorFlow
for the first time, and you
get this "No session factory
registered" error, and you're
just left scratching your head.
Like what's going on?
Well the punchline is--
if you don't want to
know the details--
use minus force load, or
on Linux, minus minus whole
archive to link in the
TensorFlow library.
But why do you need to do that?
So to understand that,
you have to jump into how
TensorFlow is built a bit more.
There are actually
hundreds and hundreds
of components in TensorFlow,
and there's no single source
file which lists all of them.
Instead, we have a pattern where
each object, each component
in the system, each
module, actually
advertises for the rest of
the system what it can do.
It registers itself
to say hey, here I am.
I can implement
this thing for you,
and then TensorFlow
as a system, actually
gets that full list
at runtime and figures
out what's actually available.
And this error is a sign
that the session factory,
the sessions, which
are some of the most
basic things, the first thing
that TensorFlow tries to grab,
the registration
mechanism hasn't worked.
So what do I mean by a
registration mechanism?
This is a super
simplified example
of an implementation of
the multiply operation
in TensorFlow.
It's a c++ class that
effectively has a few
functions, probably the most
important of which is compute,
which actually takes some
inputs, processes them,
and puts the results
into an output tensor.
And in order to let the system
let the whole of TensorFlow
know that this is
available, there
you'll see if you look
in the dot cc file,
there's something like
this, REGISTER_KERNEL line.
And the meaning of
this is saying hey,
this class, Mul
Kernel, is available
if you ever run across a
graph that has a Mul op in it,
you can use this class
to actually implement
that functionality,
and that's fantastic.
That means that we can easily
build very complex systems
with no sort of
single global list
that we have to worry about.
It's very flexible, as you
can swap modules in and out.
But it's implemented
using a bit of c++ magic,
and the way that line
REGISTER_KERNEL actually works
is it expands into something
that's kind of a more complex
version of this.
And what this is doing is it's
defining a class that pretty
much just contains
a constructor,
and the constructor
calls the registry method
to tell the rest of TensorFlow,
hey, if you've got a Mul op,
here's a factory method.
Here's a small
function that will
return classes
that will actually
implement that for you.
And then, the real
magic comes in
because a global
variable of that type
is actually declared
immediately after.
So when that global
variable is created,
which should happen before the
rest of the program is run,
before main is actually run,
then that registration core
we made, so by the time
any user code is run,
all of the objects which uses
pattern will have actually
called into the registry
and let the registry
know about them existing.
But, linkers are stock in
1978 and have no idea that c++
exists, and they're extremely
keen to get rid of any
variables that aren't
actually being used.
And they look at that global
that you just created.
They see nobody's reading from
it, nobody is writing to it,
so they say oh great, I
can just get rid of this.
They don't know that
it actually has a side
effect in its constructor.
So what happens is that
all of the register
calls get stripped out and
the first problem it hits
is that sessions themselves
aren't registered.
So what do you do?
So as I mentioned at the start,
minus minus whole archive
on Linux or minus force
load on iOS or OS X
is a flag that you have to
put into your linker flags
when you're building
your executable,
and this is the tricky
part because this is not
something we can put into the
library compilation scripts
because it's something you
need to do when you're adding
the TensorFlow to your binary.
So just to reiterate,
you ever see
the no session found
error, first thing to do
is go check your linker options
and try putting these in
to make sure you're
loading TensorFlow
without the linker
trying to get clever.
So you've got something
up and running,
and you're getting ready to put
your app out into the world.
But you really, really
care as a mobile developer
about the size of your
app, and Inception v3
is almost 100 megs,
which is appalling
if you're a mobile developer.
Like that's just mind blowing
that people would be shipping
that sort of stuff around.
But do not worry.
We actually have a
whole bunch of solutions
to help you shrink the model
size down by a massive amount.
So to understand how that
works, to get started,
you need to actually run
freeze graph script to take
a model form the
normal checkpoint
format into something that's
just a single graph def
so you can do more
easy processing after.
Then you use the
graph transform tool
to actually do a whole
bunch of optimizations.
This is a big toolbox
full of useful things
helping to speed up
and tidy up your graph.
But the most important
one for this problem
is the quantize_weights
transform,
and by default
TensorFlow will store
the weight for most models as
32-bit floating point values,
and models contain millions,
and millions, and millions
of these weights, typically.
So the Inception v3 has
over 20 million whites,
which means that you end up
with this very large, almost 100
meg model file in the end.
But those numbers
are actually usually
within fairly small
ranges, so you can actually
compress them down to 8-bit
using this quantized_weights
transform.
And you will get a very
surprisingly small loss
of accuracy, in most cases,
for a very, very big reduction
in file size.
And if you want to
get even more fancy,
this is still a very
experimental feature,
but we do have
quantized nodes which
actually does the
calculations in 8-bit as well.
And there's lots of
asterisks next to this,
depending on which model you're
using, but we're working hard,
and it's actually how we're
doing the Qualcomm integration
for example, on their DSP.
And if you're actually running
into problems with RAM usage
when you're actually
running your app.
For example, on iOS,
on older devices,
it can be very easy to
have your app killed
if you're using more than
100 megs of memory at a time.
You can actually
use memory mapping
to avoid loading the
weights explicitly
into an allocated
buffer in RAM, which
will help a lot with
both loading speed
and avoiding getting killed.
And at the end of it, you end
up with a quantized version
of Inception v3 that's
just 24 megs, and if that's
too big you can actually look
at older versions of Inception
like v1, which still gives
pretty good accuracy,
and that can be just seven megs.
So, you've actually managed
to get your model size down.
The other side of your
application bundle
is how big is your binary?
And another scary number.
TensorFlow will increase your
binary size by 12 megabytes
if you just add it
before you do any tuning,
but do not be scared.
We actually have
again, a whole bunch
of ways to reduce that size
by taking a few simple steps.
And to understand why
TensorFlow is so big,
it includes hundreds and 100 of
ops, and each one of those ops
has an implementation that
takes up a bunch of code space.
And to actually keep the
size even down to 12 megs,
we actually don't
include some data types
and some ops by
default. So if you
run into the no op
kernel found ever,
you may actually want to add
some dot cc to either the build
files or the makefile listing
of files you need to include,
depending on which system
you're actually using.
But if you're trying to
keep the binary size down,
you can run this print
selective registration header
script on your model,
and what this does
is it actually looks at what
ops your model is using,
and then creates a header
file that you can put it
in the root of your
source tree, and then
you specify the selective
registration macro,
and TensorFlow will be
compiled to only include
the implementations of
the ops that you actually
are using in your model.
For example, with
inception v3 set of ops,
you can get the binary size
increased to under 2 megabytes.
So, thanks all for listening.
I know I've been
keeping you from lunch,
so I'll wrap up now.
But I'm really excited
to see everything
that you guys are
going to be creating,
and please do get
in touch, and let me
know how you're getting
on, and how we can help.
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]